fifth street in the organ district
[Music]
the suspect has been identified as a
Connor Stephen Betts is a minimal
criminal history as an adult his traffic
violations speed founder control and
failure to yield he was wearing a mask a
bulletproof vest and hearing protection
he was armed with a point two to three
caliber like rifle with 100-round drum
magazines he has a twenty four years of
age and he is deceased fatalities from
this assault include louis Oglesby a
black female 27 years of age Megan Betts
white film female 22 years of age he is
the suspects sister Syed Salah who is a
black male 38 years of age Derrick fudge
black male 57 years of age Logan Turner
white male 30 years of age Nicholas
Coomer white male 27 years of age
Thomas McNichols black male 25 years of
age Beatrice Curtis black female 36
years of age Monica
Brickhouse black female 39 years of age
in addition there are 27 confirmed
victims who were injured and were
transferred transported to local
hospitals for treatment basic overview
of this scene of this entire incident is
now on your screen and the lower
left-hand corner you see a square that
is the approximate location of the
suspect's vehicle that was parked and
then the suspect left and then went on
to commit this assault the rectangular
area toward the the right side and more
center of the diagram is where the
suspect fires dispersed shots and killed
his first victim he then enters on to
5th Street and then there 8 other
victims killed by the suspect before
or he is fatally struck at the entrance
to net peppers which is were these
circles designates this is just a
suspect initial route so you saw that
square block our box that was on the
screen saying where he fired his initial
shots this is that area illuminated in
the daytime here and that red arrow is
the pathway he took to get the fifth
Street we're now going to show a couple
of videos of this event that will show
graphic content they will show police
officers engage this individual they
will show multiple shots being fired we
have done try to eliminate any video at
this time that shows any victims who are
shot so we'll start with the first video
these are outside of Ned peppers
the Dayton police officer running along
the top of the screen to engage the
suspect see the suspect entered the
bottom right hand corner of the screen
that's him there entering her Tempe
Internet peppers when he has struck
multiple times and he stops there and
there's another video here a little bit
different angle
you see a lot of officers who were
entering in from the upper left-hand
corner of this screen and begin heading
down the roadway there to engage the
suspect
here's one officer there another officer
coming patrol rifle
additional officers responding
officer with a sergeant with the
shotguns
next is a photographs of the suspects
vehicle which is a 2007 great soil to
Corolla next is a photo of the firearm
used by the suspect you see in the lower
left-hand corner there's double drum
magazines with have a capacity of up to
100 rounds and on the lower right hand
corner that that firearm is identifying
the officers involved in this in the
active shooting in this event include
Sergeant William Knight G at night who
came on in 1997's more than 20 year
veteran the remaining officers have been
on at roughly about three years they
include Officer Brian Rufus officer
Jeremy Campbell officer Vincent Carter
officer Ryan naval and officer David
dentling earth we've had extraordinary
assistance from many many different
agencies Montgomery County Sheriff's
Office aha State Patrol the Federal
Bureau of Investigation represent with
us here on stage alcohol tobacco
firearms owner of partners joining us
here on stage
Sinclair police department university of
dayton police department five rivers
Metroparks Kettering Police Department
Riverside police department Montgomery
counties coroner's office uber Heights
Police Department Montgomery County
Prosecutor's Office Box 21 red cross
Bellbrook police department also the US
Attorney of southwest Ohio has joined us
on stage who had been very supportive
and helpful in this investigation which
is ongoing just gonna remind you that
we're a little bit more than 12 plus
hours into this event so much is unknown
the Dade Police Department homicide you
know we handling the Criminal
Investigation administrative
investigation will be conducted by
professional standards Bureau and that
occurs anytime an officer discharges a
firearm for a police department policy
for the five officers that one sergeant
we're gonna be placed on administrative
leave that is per protocol
we are still asking for assistance to
this investigation notwithstanding the
substantial local and federal and even
state resources dedicated to this
investigations if there's any
information guard as incident we were
regards requested to be relayed to
Dayton Police Department by calling the
tip line at nine three seven two two
five six two one seven there's a Family
Assistance Center has been established
at the Dayton Convention Center where
you are at and can be contacted directly
at nine three seven three three three
eight four three zero and for additional
information please follow our Twitter
page at Dayton police that is the
entirety of the presentation at this
time the status of this investigation
once again to reiterate we are very very
early into this investigation any
suggestion at this time of motive would
be irresponsible we do not have
sufficient information to answer the
question and everyone wants to know why
we do not have that answer at this time
we will clearly pursue this
investigation to try to understand
motivation in this crime to assuming
that there is a motivation that's
understandable so that's still before us
we have a lot of evidence to process
through from digital evidence to
physical evidence to phone evidence so
much much investigation is before us so
we're very early on this is very basic
preliminary information I'm able to
provide at this time with that I will
open up to any questions you may have
today but there was a report that while
the shooter had his rifle out someone
grabbed the end of the rifle and so he
dropped it and grabbed a handgun started
shooting continuing in that we have no
information to substantiate that at all
there was there was a superior officer
after the suspect was down who removed
the rifle from underneath him or the
weapon from underneath him that happened
but I have no information to corroborate
what you were what you just mentioned
we're gonna have to do this in orderly
fashion
no she was not the first victim but she
was one of the initial victims right as
the he came out of that alleyway she and
a another male who is was a companion of
the suspect was shot and wounded so they
were victims and initially after the
first person was shot so very close
proximity I can't speak to the evidences
recovered we clearly did recover
evidence there much of this we have to
examine so I can't really comment
further on that at this time well
there's more than one gun but they can
tell you that particular weapon that you
saw was ordered online from Texas but
transferred to the suspect at a local
firearms dealer here in this area
there's also a shotgun that was acquired
from a local firearms dealer here two
different dealers but the ridge that
weapon originated in Texas
let me say there's nothing in this
individuals history or record that would
have precluded him from purchasing that
firearm there is no indication that that
is illegal at this time to mention it I
don't think I understand your question
he's a white male we have no evidence
suggest that this there's a biased
motive in this crime at this time it is
certainly dozens were fired I don't
think we have an absolute count at this
point so I don't want to put a number
out there and have it not be accurate
but dozens of rounds were fired
well I would tell you that what was
crucial in their response was the
availability of both shotgun and patrol
rifle that was crucial that was a
commitment we made really well over a
decade ago and even added to that
inventory since my tenure is chief I'm
in my twelfth year now so recognizing
the potential threats that we could face
particularly people wearing ballistic
armor we know we have to have the kind
of equipment and weaponry to be able to
thwart that that was pretty crucial in
this case and I'm sorry you're I think
he had a question yes yes the the
information we have is they all came in
the same vehicle but they separated at
some point no information in that regard
yes
well I think you can imagine this is a
nightmare for them and I think they are
struggling as you can understand we've
had a chance to have contact with them
this weekend pardon we have no
information to suggest that none at this
time we had an opportunity to talk to
the individual who wrote in a vehicle
with them so when it his part of her
investigation that's ongoing yes we do
have information but we're not going to
release it at this time
[Music]
I can't confirm and I'm gonna come
because it's gonna speak the potential
motive right I mean that's what people
are trying to get to here there is far
too much information that we have to
review before we can even begin a
conversation about possible motive and I
will not talk about any potential slice
of evidence is value or not at this time
is just way too early and I'll just
reconfirm we have a the shotgun wasn't
yes so there are two weapons but one of
which was using the aside well let me
just say that those weapons eventually
wound up at that location they separated
at some point later in that evening so
what he did during that time that they
were no longer together is a question
mark in our investigation and something
we're gonna have to determine I think
that question was already asked and I
said we're not going to talk about any
evidence at this room
you know I I don't have a number for you
right now we were trying to confirm that
we basically do ballistics checks that
we look for shell casings at the scene
then we have to match that against
magazine capacity and rounds missing and
that's not always a precise comparison
so I don't have a precise number for you
at this
we don't have any reason to believe that
any of the persons deceased were shot by
other than the assailant at this time
they did at some point in time I don't
think we have a precise time for that
but clearly it was some point in the
evening that they did part ways I don't
have that veil between right now we
don't have that specific information I
don't think we have that known with
absolute certainty there was a vehicle's
shot early on in that exchange rifle
right as our officers were either
engaging or about to engage so I can't
really speak to that precisely that's
really something we can't tell at this
point it's it's a question it's a
nagging question and I just don't have
the answer we're trying to sort through
that ourselves
not that I'm aware of
not that we're aware of so we really
don't know if there that was somehow
love importance we don't have I think
anything precise on the other 27 do we
one critical ones critical well it's
interesting because we already have a
concentration present or just because
it's an entertainment venue we realize a
lot of people come to Oregon district
I've been there very recently so
certainly we know a lot of folks are be
there and we have police officers
present because of that reason so will
this causes to evaluate we will evaluate
everything that touches on this incident
just to determine whether we do need to
anything differently but there were
certainly plenty of officers present
that acted virtually instantaneously and
effectively ended this in 30 seconds
it was crucial had this individual made
it through the doorway of net peppers
with that level of weaponry there have
been a catastrophic injury and loss of
life so stopping him before he could get
inside there where you saw the people
that were running in there for
protection
you
I'm not aware of that being the case
they were obtained legal yes unlike none
no he was he's one of the ones that was
injured transported the hospital that is
correct
yeah ballistic vest that's some sort of
a mass correct I don't have the
information available well let's say was
one in the same they all came together I
do want to pause for me because I want
like the FBI has a site that we want to
get out publicly Todd if you come join
us and introduce yourself
yeah I'm Todd Wickersham I'm the FBI
special agent in charge for this part of
the state and WWF pigo V Dayton is
shooting right so one more Dayton
shooting after ww2 FBI gov back slash
Dayton shooting and what we can people
can submit their if they have videos if
they have other social media associated
with this shooting that they think would
be a value to the investigation this is
where they can go to upload this to get
it in the right hands as we're working
jointly with Dayton on this
investigation
Thank You Ben do you want to mention
anything regarding the Department of
Justice attention to this matter chief I
just wanted to say on behalf of the
United States that